for Europe it just keeps getting worse
Nordstrom gas pipelines connecting
Russia to Europe scientists recorded
explosions in the Baltic Sea before
detecting three simultaneous leaks and
this comes at a Tipping Point time for
Vladimir Putin's war in Ukraine Russia's
North stream gas pipelines to Europe
just blew up and it might have been the
U.S if it was the us we're getting real
close to World War III let me explain as
you're watching this these pipelines are
spilling an insane amount of natural gas
into the ocean making it one of the
greatest environmental disasters of
recent times but this disaster was no
accident these pipelines are made of
steel nearly two inches thick protected
by another four inches of reinforced
concrete and as soon as the leaks were
detected Swedish officials would put a
two giant underwater explosions in that
area making this one of the biggest acts
of sabotage of our time the question is
who did it if you listen to mainstream
media the answer is obvious Putin did it
he's a Madman who else would it be NATO
this morning calling those mysterious
leaks in in the Nordstrom pipelines
sabotage sabotage is thought to be
behind three leaks in the north stream
natural gas pipelines connecting Russia
to Europe he started off as a autocrat
became a dictator and now he's a Madman
he wants zero chance of Europe Ever
Getting Russian gas again at first that
seems like the obvious answer even we
assumed that it was probably Putin in a
recent video however once you actually
take a second to think about it Putin
blowing up his own pipeline literally
makes no sense whatsoever natural gas is
one of the main sources of Putin's
wealth of his power get this Europe paid
Russia 39 billion euros for energy in
just the first two months of the Ukraine
Invasion that is twice as much as the
aid they gave Ukraine and a lot of that
was thanks to the north stream pipeline
these pipelines were the last piece of
Leverage Putin had over Europe to get
them to stop supporting Ukraine he
already shut off the pipelines why would
he need to blow it up now if even if the
EU wanted to come crawling back to Putin
begging for natural gas in exchange for
giving Putin Ukraine the EU wouldn't be
able to because the pipeline has been
blown up but you know who would benefit
from the Russian pipelines blowing up
America thank you think about it no
pipeline means Putin has less power it
means he has a higher chance of losing
in Ukraine it means Europe has to go to
another country that has a lot of
natural gas to sell a country like
America and the US knows this in fact
here's what Biden had to say about
Russia's gas pipelines back in February
if Russia invades that means tanks or
troops crossing the uh the border of
Ukraine again then there will be we
there will be no longer on Norse team
too we we will bring it into it we will
bring an end to it and eight months
later an end has been brought to it and
right after the explosions a former
polish foreign minister who's got a
picture with him and Biden together on
his Twitter Banner tweeted out three
simple cryptic words thank you USA that
tweet has now been deleted oh and what
do you know the day after the pipelines
were sabotaged would you look at that a
new pipeline was unveiled that carries
non-russian gas to Europe how convenient
right man imagine just how nice it would
be to have your main competitor
magically blow up the day before you
launch your new business
stay dangerous and this is the north
stream sabotage
behind closed doors poon might have been
one of the wealthiest people in the
world he is basically the equivalent of
a feudal Lord during the medieval times
Lords were the wealthy powerful Elite
that owned all the land back in the day
think about it poone's got a ton of real
estate he has his own Army of soldiers
protecting him you might as well call
him Lord Putin but lucky for you you too
can be called lord whatever your name is
thanks to established titles if you're
not familiar with established titles it
allows you to buy approximately one
square foot of land in Scotland for just
under fifty dollars and the thing about
owning land in Scotland is that there is
an old Scottish tradition where land
owners are called Lawrence and ladies
that means for just under fifty dollars
you can put that your lord on your
credit cards on your plane tickets
dating profiles and more to show that
you are above the peasantry to be clear
this is not an official warship but is
still pretty cool you're gonna get a
certificate it will feature a unique
plot number for your plot of land in
Scotland and if you act fast you can
actually get your plot of land near mine
so we can meet Lords together these make
a super unique last minute GIF that
would definitely set you apart from
everyone else's mediocre gifts there's
an exclusive sale going off for viewers
of this channel where you'll get 10 off
any purchase when you go to establish
titles.com jaketrain and use code jtran
so pause the video and become a lord
today by going to established house.com
and using code jtran with the link below
thanks to established titles for
sponsoring this video
when looking at the nordstream pipeline
sabotage it's important to remember that
America is no stranger to sabotaging
other countries launching coups funding
revolutions sabotaging countries
toppling foreign leaders launching
psychological warfare campaigns on
foreign populations is not the exception
for the CIA but the norm
such a norm that there's a giant
Wikipedia page dedicated to all of it
and we've covered a bunch of examples of
it on this channel and the powers that
be in America that orchestrate all these
interventions have been very open about
their intentions towards Russia and
Russian natural gas
but to really understands just how far
the U.S is willing to go to [ __ ]
Russia you have to go back in time to
2014 to the Ukrainian Revolution
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
Ukraine was in an uproar just a few
months before the Ukrainian president at
the time Yanukovych turned down a
business deal with Europe when Russia
made him a better offer
protests on either side erupted all
around the country and things got
violent
over a hundred protesters were dead by
February and would you look at that it
looks like the chaos was engineered or
at least supported by none other than
the us and it makes sense why not meddle
in Ukraine at this fragile time in their
history to make sure they lean more
towards the west and it worked
Yanukovych ended up fleeing the country
and the new Ukrainian government that
took power was pro-west
and that's where Condoleezza Rice comes
in Condoleezza Rice was America's
national security advisor in 2001 and
Secretary of State under George W bush
so she's got a lot of experience with
spreading democracy all over the world
in 2014 when all this upheaval was first
happening in Ukraine she openly admitted
how the U.S wanted Europe to stop buying
Russian natural gas and buy American
Natural Gas instead but now we need to
have tougher sanctions and I'm afraid at
some point this is going to probably
have to involve oil and gas the Russian
economy is vulnerable eighty percent of
Russian exports are in oil gas and
minerals people say well the Europeans
will run out of energy well the Russians
will run out of cash before the
Europeans run out of energy and I
understand that it's uncomfortable to
have an effect on business ties in this
way but this is one of the few
instruments that we have to over the
long run you simply want to change the
structure of energy dependence you want
to depend more on the North American
Energy platform the tremendous Bounty of
oil and gas that we're finding in North
America you want to have pipelines that
don't go through Ukraine and Russia so
the U.S wasn't involved in the 2014
Ukraine Revolution and here we have
America's national security advisor
admitting that we know Russia's economy
is dependent on natural gas and that we
want to change the structure of energy
dependence in Europe
to have Europe depend more on the
American Energy platform that you want
to have pipelines that don't go through
Ukraine and Russia oh interesting there
is not a pipeline that goes through
Ukraine and Russia anymore you simply
want to change the structure of energy
dependence you want to have pipelines
that don't go through Ukraine and Russia
but it doesn't stop there
this is Victoria Newland she is also
very well versed in the art of spreading
democracy across the globe
she had power during the invasion of
Afghanistan she was a key player in the
war on Iraq she personally made the call
to overthrow the Libyan government in
2011. whose proxy wars aggression
ongoing occupations are all a part of
her Stellar resume and you want to know
what she said before Russia invaded
Ukraine if Russia invades Ukraine one
way or another nordstream 2 will not
move forward
she was taking notes when Condoleezza
Rice was talking
and as we mentioned earlier the day
after Nordstrom was sabotaged the new
pipeline called the Baltic pipe was
unveiled this pipeline is not Russian
and doesn't carry Russian natural gas
instead it was built by Norway Poland
and Denmark starting back in 2013 and
runs through around the same area as the
nordstream pipelines did
on top of that it was even finished a
month ahead of schedule very convenient
indeed this means that Norway Poland and
Denmark are getting the economic power
that Russia once had
even the Secretary of State Anthony
blinken said after the pipeline was
destroyed that this was a huge victory
for the U.S even though it was
absolutely something the U.S did not do
quote it's a tremendous opportunity to
once and for all remove the dependence
on Russian energy and thus take away
from Vladimir Putin the weaponization of
energy as a means of advancing his
Imperial designs
quote
foreign
ever since people started speculating if
the US was involved in the sabotage the
U.S has been pushing back hard saying
that anyone who questions the narrative
has been brainwashed by Russian
propaganda sabotage at Sea that's what
President Biden is calling the leaks and
explosions on the Nordstrom pipelines
Russia is most likely behind this the
United States had nothing to do with it
it's just Russian propaganda and
disinformation but why the hard pushback
the reason is simple it's because this
is literally an act of war and because
it might be true remember that Colonial
Pipeline on the east coast of America
that was hacked back in 2021 remember
how frightening that was for the U.S to
have a critical part of their
infrastructure compromised yeah now
imagine instead of hackers attacking the
colonial pipeline it was Russia and
instead of using ransomware they used
bombs yeah that would be the start of
World War III
that's why in this case the US has to do
everything in its power to distance
itself from the Nordstrom sabotage
because if word gets out that the U.S
was involved somehow why shouldn't Putin
be able to sabotage America's
infrastructure why shouldn't Putin be
able to bomb our pipelines attack our
electricity grid cut our internet cables
after all it was America that started it
and then boom America's proxy war
against Russia now turns into a hot War
so far Common Sense points to Putin not
being the one who blew up the pipeline
and there's no direct evidence that the
U.S was involved but what do you think I
guess you have to ask yourself if you
were in Putin's shoes would you blow up
your own pipeline let us know in the
comments below
[Music]
long list of all the coups and regime
changes the US has orchestrated well
there was one coup that started it all
this coup was so effective that at that
time it was one of the most successful
CIA operations ever but it was also the
coup that planted the seeds of Middle
Eastern Terror so many Terror events all
the wars and Chaos in the Middle East
they can all be traced back to this one
coup that the CIA orchestrated if you
ask the government they'll say it was to
stop communism to spread freedom but in
reality it was for one thing and one
thing only foil this was the coup that
started America's love affair with
Middle Eastern Oil we're talking about
the Iran coup of 1953 and it was a
bloodbath
unfortunately talking about Terror
events and tragedy and all the other
stuff the CIA was having fun with would
definitely get demonetized on YouTube so
we've released a private documentary on
the Iranian coup and the roots of Middle
Eastern Terror available only to members
of this channel
members have been loving it and it's
personally one of our favorite private
documentaries all you have to do to
watch is scroll down and click that join
button below when you join you'll get
instant access to this private
documentary new ones coming out every
single month and access to all our
previous documentaries as well like our
newest one on the profitable business of
vaccines everything that Society will
never teach you about how the world
works
and there's a refund policy too unlike
most YouTube memberships so if you join
and you don't think it's worth it email
us within your first month of joining
for the first time and we will
personally refund you for your first
month after your first month there is no
refund so scroll down and click that
join button now
so who do you think did it let me know
in the comments below I talked to some
International friends and the general
consensus around the world seems to be
that the US did it but yeah if you're
new here this is one of the biggest
channels on YouTube for documentaries on
money power war and crime so you can
learn how the world really works instead
of becoming a victim to it so if you
like that philosophy if you want to be
more dangerous click that subscribe
button below it's free you can
unsubscribe whenever you want and you
can leave me your best hate comments
whenever you want as well so you have
nothing to lose you can follow me on
Instagram Jake trim but that is going to
wrap it up thanks for being part of the
watch the end Club stay dangerous out
there and I will see you guys in the
next one
foreign
[Music]